so those are some of your mantras or
your ways of working through it because
I know there's so many times when you
probably just want to just abandon
something but can't we all go through
the stuff so yeah what keeps you on
track so that you don't yeah that's a
good question but it so you don't give
up basically yeah yeah that's a good
question um I love with his name Stephen
do you guys know the book the war of art
is a steamy pressing crestfield right
okay yeah I love the book the war part
by steven pressfield that that has a
great prescription for getting through
writer's block and you know you can sort
of pull from that to apply to any sort
of challenge that you're meeting along
the production phase and his advice I
think you know the bottom line is in
order to beat writers block you simply
have to continue writing you know and
you write each and every day and the
only way around it is to go through it
you know and so in another thing another
thing that I found myself telling myself
a lot through lasource was who's going
to tell the story if I give up what's
going to happen to the story if I'm not
around to put my blood sweat and tears
into this film that no one else well and
no one will have the privilege of
hearing about this amazing man as
amazing accomplishments and you know I
feel like the world would have missed
out if they didn't get introduced to
Joey in this way and so yeah there's
this obligation to do the story justice
and to tell the story properly that that
is a pretty good motivating factor I
think for me so really having a sense of
purpose and not just all I want to win
this award or hoping to get into Sunday
so I'm really having that sense of
purpose behind actual yeah the awards
the wards just can't drive you you know
I mean because because they rarely come
and when they do they're really not all
that rewarding you know and
what you find i think at the end of the
process is what's the most rewarding
thing is is the feeling of accomplishing
this great feat of actually finishing a
film and then sharing it with people
sharing with audiences and and and
watching the sort of ripple effect that
takes place when you finish a film the
people that are affected and inspired
and and in some cases the actual change
that takes place it takes place as far
as you know policy or in our case it was
a village of 5,000 people getting water
for the first time in their lives and so
that's really the most rewarding thing
of making movies i think is watching
that ripple effect
you